when it comes to Dakota Johnson's
relationship with Coldplay frontman
Chris Martin the actress is staying
tight-lipped the 28 year old graces the
cover of Tatler's November issue and
during her interview with the mag she
was asked about her secretive romance
with the singer to which she replied
quote I'm not going to talk about it but
I am very happy the Fifty Shades of Grey
star also opened up about embracing
overtly sexual roles take him off in
here right here quote I find it powerful
I've always been fascinated by women who
are in touch with their sexuality who
are proud of it
who are not passive about it I don't
think that in order to be respected and
in order to feel powerful that you need
to be sexless and while Johnson's fifty
Shades days may be behind her she is
busier than ever with her new film bad
times at the El Royale hitting theaters
October 12th would you mind opening the
door EG caught up with johnson at the
premiere and she dished on the role as a
criminal on a mission I really like that
she's like just unapologetically angry
and I really appreciate that
[Music]